[Applause]
that is the sound of revolution and they
think it's almost there now they've
never left the streets and they say they
won't until a new government takes
office however long that may be and to
make the point they came out again in
huge means after a few days of genuine
concern that Sudan's youth led
revolution was about to turn nasty it
all changed
military concessions promised of a
civilian dominated government brought
the party back to the streets of
Khartoum they braved the baking heat
throughout the day every age group every
class is represented on the road to
protest yes I'm coming here to feel good
because there's the people that are
looking for freedom and they are looking
for a good things in the country do you
think you're almost there the revolution
is almost from inside military
headquarters soldiers watch through the
railings what they're seeing
couldn't have been countenance just a
few weeks ago people pause to pay their
respects to the dead of the revolution
their pictures laid out on pavements
through the crowds the militia
promising their protection ask unimpeded
they come from all over town as passive
difference.this a few days ago it felt
that all of the momentum that was in
place for change had gone another was a
breakdown in communications between the
opposition and military that's changed
now they said it'd be cool to the
streets in large numbers they really
believe that they've got a revolution
within their grasp they're not there yet
there's a massive change yet again the
citizens of Sudan are putting their
faith in people they don't actually know
but who have guided this revolution away
from the spotlight Nabil Adeeb is the
legal expert pushing for a long
transition newly found democracy can he
says be lost too easily
take a look at Egypt they went to
election within few months and they lost
the revolution lost
they brought Muslim Brotherhood's
because then people who had money and
organization will win the elections we
need to establish you see a society that
can deal with election after 30 years of
dictatorship
these are heavy days indeed for Sudan
the revolution isn't won yet but the
will remains undid and they're moving in
the right direction and they're prepared
to fight for mr. Ramsay Sky News cartoon